au-dessus de ces dépôts de pétrole des
flammes immenses et des colonnes de
fumées noir de plusieurs dizaines de
mètres
d'eau ces réservoirs situés dans la
ville de klingzi à l'ouest de la Russie
ont été visés par une attaque de drone
ukrainien des terroristes ukrainiens ont
tenté d'attaquer des infrastructures sur
le territoire de la ville de clincy à
l'aide d'un drone ce vendredi Kief a
même revendiqué l'attaque l'incendie
couvrirait une surface de 1000 m²r selon
l'agence de presse rustas aucun blessé
n'aurait été déploré une frappe sur un
site stratégique pour affaiblir l'ennemi
ce n'est pas une première pour Kief la
région est régulièrement la cible
d'attaque de drone de l'armée
ukrainienne ces derniers jours Kiev dit
avoir réussi une autre offensive sur un
terminal pétrolier russe près de
Saint-Pétersbourg un incendie dans la
troisème plus grande raffinerie de
Russie au sud de Moscou aurait également
été constaté ce vendredi avant que les
flammes ne soient éteintes selon les
médias
russes